qui
la moitié de la population de chats
diène et de religion musulmane
l'autre moitié est composée de chrétiens
et d'animistes schématiquement on place
les chrétiens au sud et les musulmans
honorent en fait et frontières
coloniales du tchad ont enfermé dans un
même espace
quelques 200 ethnies tribus ou plan
parlant plus de 100 langues et vivent
repliés sur eux mêmes comme ici à boubou
boo boo est un petit village de la
brousse du geer à une région située à
l'est djamena la capitale du tchad
les habitants du village sont des hadjis
rails ce qui signifie dans leur dialecte
kenga peuple des rochers ils sont une
centaine de familles à vivre sur ce
morceau de terre issue du sable et des
pierres ici musulman chrétien et
animiste font bon ménage autour de la
nécessité de vivre
il y a quelques années seulement une
petite communauté chrétienne s'est formé
dans le village c'est un père jésuite
venus les aider à gérer leurs récoltes
pour éviter les temps de famine qui leur
a enseigné ainsi les premiers principes
de la foi chrétienne
au sud dans un contexte musulmans et
animistes ou l'existence de dieu est
perçu comme une évidence surnaturel
cette fois tout jeune encore très simple
s'exprime d'abord par une adoration
chanter plus qu'elle n'implique une
véritable exigence de comportement non
je pense à ça suffit voilà ça remplit
pas les oreilles je suis d'accord mais
ça suffit
bonbons et des assemblages vivre voilà
mes frères je dis oui sinon je vous ai
demandé c'est la conversion ce
changement de vie pour un terme à
l'aventuré quelques impatients bandits
quand tu deviens que le couple est très
bonne
c'est bien quand on joue comme ça c'est
bon le toto seconde empreinte
mais quand tu prends tout le temps tu
souhaites tu peux pas marcher ça ce
n'est plus il faut changer ça tant que
chrétien je peux voir deux ou trois cas
le bois soit pas 50
kg dont le sauveteur fruits de la terre
et du travail des hommes pour tous le
présentons il deviendra le pain de la
vie
c'est pour la première fois que le
célèbre l'eucharistie dans cette
communauté
parce que cette année seulement qu'ils
ont commencé à travaillé dix ans dans ce
secteur sud
alors bon je fais mes tournées moment
programmation peut-être me verront une
fois tous les deux mois c'est un peu de
tout mais bon quelquefois de passage
comme ça de courtoisie vous avez un jeu
malade j'ai dit bonjour quand même aux
catéchistes paix auquel tu es chrétien
que je rencontre quand on essaie ou bien
quand on essaie de les garder les champs
le christ est perçu comme le sauveur
c'est lui qui vient de nous qui viennent
nous apporter la bonne nouvelle en faire
quelquefois aussi oui c'est comme une
divinité parce que le concept
théologique échappe toujours au niveau
de la langue il ya toujours des
nouvelles entrées à des gens qui
viennent donc ils viennent embrasser
cette foi chrétienne donc à une
évolution parce qu'au démarrage ils
n'étaient pas nombreux essais papoter
avec une poignée de personnes déjà une
dizaine des menaces a évolué je crois
que nous comptons tout les membres de la
communauté ils seront peut-être 60 ya
certains qui sont vraiment disons
évangéliser et qui vivent un certain
changement dans leur vie quotidienne
pour yad autres peut-être bon il réside
encore mais de fait
l'espoir est positif enfin au niveau de
la cohabitation elle est parfaite parce
que dans la même famille vous trouverez
musulmans peut-être protestants et puis
c'est de la religion traditionnelle
surtout les anciens ils sont presque
tous de la religion traditionnelle vous
allez constater vous n'y a pas assez de
vieux dents dans cette communauté
mais la cohabitation en tout cas
parfaitement à mon avis à paraître le
mois de tensions entre musulmans
chrétiens ou protestons cette bagarre
est vraiment presque inexistante
les voisins musulmans ou animistes
seront aussi invités au repas
la traditionnelle boule 2000 une céréale
proche du blé dont ils font leur
principale nourriture sera agrémentée
d'un peu de viande en l'honneur des
invités et chrétiens sont ici ceux qui
rassemblent autour d'une table pour
manger et discuter ensemble de la vie
quotidienne du village nous parle de
partage et pose ainsi les premières
pierres d'une communauté humaine
fraternelle
quoi
il
à une journée de marche de boubous
habite quine le gros bourg voisin
les différences sociales et religieuses
sont plus marqués le commerce est
essentiellement musulman est alimenté
par les pays voisins la libye de kadhafi
surtout c'est un islam plus récent très
prosélyte qui empiète sur la laïcité du
pouvoir est à l'origine de secteurs
d'affrontements entre chrétiens et
musulmans
je viens
les regards envers les chrétiens sont
teintées de méfiance
alors que l'islam est une religion
commerciale et comptable qui marque de
façon ostensible son territoire les
chrétiens ne sont pas considérés digne
de confiance et sont tenus à la
discrétion dans un état considéré comme
l'état des musulmans et c'est seulement
à la proche de djamena la capitale le
long du fleuve chari que se posent
véritablement la question du dialogue
islamo chrétien
oui
les chrétiens ce qui s'affiche comptait
lisons sont pas nombreux notre
communauté
ce que la pression sociale et de
l'ailette ce qu'elle est on ne peut
s'afficher que si on vit une expérience
intérieure comme à la effective jeudi
mais je crois qu'il n'est moins sûr mais
il ne m'appartient pas de dire si dieu
existe ou non parce que la fois ces
communes et c'est d'abord une expérience
si concrètement je n'arrive pas à
découvrir qu'ils devaient existe ce que
je te dirai oui ou non elle n'a pas de
sens il faut que toi tu vivre cette
expérience là de l'existant d'edu dans
ta vie contre or cette expérience l'a
effectivement j'ai vécu c'est plutôt ça
qui me qui me renforce en tout cas qui
ne la sueur dans n'importe où où je suis
parce que justement les bleus où je suis
je suis censé être musulman
sociologiquement ce sens être musulman
et donc c'est plus facile
voilà deux atouts car pour être
tranquille il faut être musulman parce
que dans les lieux publics les
rencontres en tout cas le souci des
parents c'est que j'ai je pousse la
religion qui est la leur à 3 mai par
avions fait une expérience qui ont fait
l'expérience
deux fois il y en a qui m'ont dit
aimablement que vraiment ils souhaitent
ils désir profond de moins que
j'aime islamistes j'ai retourné la même
question j'ai dit moi enfin moi je désir
très fort que vraiment vous vivez
l'expérience
voyez donc en sûrement pour peu qu'on
discute pour peu qu'on discute parce que
il se trouve malheureusement que les
musulmans que je côtoie ici sont des
musulmans mes parents surtout là c'est
pas des musulmans instruits dans la
religion
il y en a qui sont un sommet sont peu
nombreux à le contrôler avec cela nous
pouvons discuter sans problème nous
discutions c'est un peu le cas de tout
le monde grands frères la religion c'est
mon avis avant tout une histoire d'amour
je pense que mon petit frère je le
connais je vais proposer de plus
non pas par conformisme parce que
j'estime au fond de moi même je peux pas
aimer
est-ce que nous voit
je crois que c'est la mère l'instant moi
je me sens un peu et fortifiée du moment
où j'ai un musulman qui discute avec -
sans passion et à qui je peux me livrer
aux 600 patients bien sûr et je me dis
bon dieu il ne peut pas en tout cas l'a
enfermé dans une conception
ça c'est une certitude que cette affirmé
à moi une personne personne aucun être
humain ne peut enfermer dieu dans une
conception six mois je j'ai vécu une
expérience personnelle sont alors le
peut mais le t2 de mon cas c'est un peu
ça la fois dans ces conditions là qu'est
ce que moi j'aurais à imposer ce que
c'est dieu qui met la fois nous disons
c'est les chrétiens les musulmans il
disparaît malheureusement ça c'est à
cause de l'ignorance je crois que c'est
l'ignorance qui est la cause de tout ça
il ya des incompréhensions des gens qui
dans le pire des cas arrivent jusqu'à
enlever le long mais j'ai dit mais c'est
un peu c'est un peu bête quoi animer
nous musulmans nous pensons que dieu à
part continuellement parler aux hommes à
travers le prophète dit rien de ses
prophètes scemama ce que nous proposons
aux chrétiens et aux autres de ne pas
reconnaître la place maintenant
l'islam traditionnel qu'on appelle islam
noir dont est issue la famille jean et
est foncièrement tolérant et enraciné
dans le terroir africain protégé
seulement de leurs murs de sable
les deux familles chrétiennes et
musulmanes vive 6,6 en harmonie et
enrichissent mutuellement leur foi en
dieu
dans un pays où l'espérance de vie est
de 45 ans l'église a un rôle à jouer
dans l'éducation des enfants et la
formation des jeunes
même si elles restent minoritaires au
tchad
elle est synonyme de développement et
cherche à témoigner de la fraternité
avec le monde musulman
on laisse la miilos anton ça très fort
il n'y a pas de d'abord de liens
personnels à dieu ça n'existe pas ou
très peu
extrêmement lointain et puisque c'est
pas un dieu fait homme c'est un an
absolument dans la visage du fils de
dieu sait si nous avons un groupe islamo
chrétien et je sens que les chrétiens
sont en train de bouger sur la nécessité
pour faire l'unité de ce pays
de commencer véritablement un dialogue
avec l'islam alors mon rôle c'est
vraiment de donner de l'espérance à ces
jeunes dans une société britannique
roger en mini espérances et souvent j'ai
entendu dans des partages chez nous
c'est pas la charité qui a pu pousser
les crs honnêtement
lisons la ressource en ils sont
combatifs comme j'ai jamais vu dans
d'autres pays
en tout cas moi je
je tire mon chapeau parce que quand ils
ont travaillé toute une nuit pour des
examens
trois machines en vente 10 fois plus
combatif que nos jeunes français il
émerveille très souvent
rien
le conseil islamique mondial prévoyait
que le chat serait entièrement islamisé
en l'an 2000 et a multiplié les mosquées
les écoles coraniques
on y apprend par coeur à la lettre des
textes du coran sans aucune
interprétation temporel ou spirituelle
l'exégèse pratiquement inexistante et
réservé à une élite
le tchad est un pays de religion est un
pays de deux grandes religions c'est un
pays d'islam et de chrétiens - on
comprend sa religion plus on s'enferme
dans un fanatisme abjecte et on pense
qu'on est con est autorisé à détruire
les autres et
je fais un effort pour comprendre ma
religion et chaque fois que je fais cet
effort là ma religion me recommande de
connaître notre religion
voyez vous parce que
dans l'islam il ya des passages assez
sublime dans le coran ou vous n'êtes pas
bon musulman
si vous ne tenez pas compte des livres
révélés des prophètes
dedieu des apôtres de dieu etc etc et
pour mon pays pour le tchad pour notre
pays il me semble que le dialogue entre
les religions
le dialogue islamo-chrétien à travers
les cercles de réflexion au niveau de la
jeunesse au niveau des gens adultes dans
les temples dans les mosquées dans les
églises est une condition de notre
sur lui
et
les musulmans d'un côté près de koh
lanta la lettre
il n'est pas de le foot c'est comme ça
qu'ils sont enseignés les chrétiens on
essaie on essaie de transcender la
lettre pour vivre l'esprit de la
religion la lettre tue mais l'esprit
vivifie ce que dit l'enseignement
chrétien
nous avons le devoir d'édifier les
autres et si on ne pense pas à édifier
les autres bons ils vont nous prendre
pour des gens des hérétiques des
quartiers des gens qui ne croient pas
qu'une pratique pas qui est que c'est le
salut vient par seulement ils ne nous
voient pas plier malheureusement on n'a
pas la sensation de plier en public de
prier dans les rues de faire nos écoles
coraniques dans les rues sous les arbres
à l'ombre des murs nous avons au lieu de
payeurs les airs de payeurs alors nos
prières sont peut-être plus discrète et
ça il ne le vendra
la paix soit avec vous en cette journée
où les chrétiens du tchad ont décidé
d'unir leurs prières pour la paix nous
voici rassemblés ce matin dans la
cathédrale notre dame de l'apec pour
prier à cette intention
nous déplorons que notre pays divisé par
des décennies de guerre et nos
populations dressées les unes contre les
autres ignorent la pratique de la
charité qui est l'apprentissage de la
construction de la fraternité
universelle
à
oh
les troupeaux laissé en liberté un
recherche de nourriture des vastes
parfois les champs de mil et réduisant
ainsi à néant les récoltes succèdent
alors très vite un affrontement sanglant
entre les agriculteurs et les éleveurs
le christianisme ne s'est véritablement
développé au tchad qu après 1945
cette jeune église a entrepris de lutter
contre les conséquences de la
confrontation traditionnelle entre le
nord des éleveurs musulmans et le sud
des agriculteurs animistes ou chrétiens
et
les religions ne sont pas responsables
du mal-vivre tchadien déterminé par les
traditions claniques l'héritage colonial
et un islam noir ou vert à la foi des
chrétiens l'existence africaine est
cependant communautaire l'important
c'est le mil dans le guerra pour
prévenir les mauvaises récoltes
les tchadiens partagent les mêmes silo
de sauvegarde est là dans cette
communion de l'essentiel chrétiens et
musulmans se retrouvent partenaires d'un
même destin
à
ouah